the protein data bank archive is an
online repository of 3d structures of
proteins and nucleic acids all
structures in the pdb were
experimentally determined and for every
structure the pdb contains the x y and z
coordinates of each atom
rcspdb is one of the organizations that
manages the pdb archive it makes the
data publicly available on rcsb.org
where it also provides tools for query
analysis and visualization
rcsb pdb also maintains an educational
portal pdb101 accessible to everyone
free of charge at pdb101.rcsb.org
pdb101 offers a diverse array of
teaching resources highlighting the
fundamental connection between the 3d
structure of a protein and its
biological function
the materials are organized by type
accessible through the top menu and by
topic accessible through the browser
one of the key resources on pdb 101 is
molecule of the month
each column focuses on one structure
from the pdb archive and includes an
introduction to the structure and
function of the molecule a discussion of
the molecules relevance to human health
and welfare and an interactive viewer
enabling exploration of relevant
molecular features in 3d
under the learn tab pdb 101 features
various resources that can supplement
any curriculum with 3d structure driven
activities for all types of learners
looking for hands-on learning resources
bring pdb 101's hands-on paper models
into the classroom building these models
will help students to become familiar
with key aspects of protein structure
additionally pdb 101 provides 3d
printable models that highlight
interactions between a protein and its
ligands
pdb 101 also features molecular
animations explaining general topics
such as what proteins are and how
enzymes function as well as more focused
topics like pain signaling and ion pumps
pdb101 also contains interactive
animations that enable students to
digitally explore the world of proteins
for example the interactive molecular
machinery poster provides a proteomic
tour from the cell membrane to the
nucleus offering 3d views for each of
the proteins featured
looking for a class project where
students can combine research and
science communication the video
challenge for high school students is an
annual event where students research a
medically relevant science topic and
create a two-minute video combining the
topic's molecular and public health
aspects
pdb 101 also offers a variety of
comprehensive curricular modules under
the teach tab covering topics ranging
from biomolecular structures and models
to molecular immunology
these modules are fully outfitted with
learning objectives hands-on activities
and before and after tests that enable
teachers to assess student understanding
finally if you would like to bring
advanced 3d protein structure
visualization into the classroom the
interactive molestar viewer is available
on rcsb.org
the mall star viewer is accessible from
the structure summary page of a given
protein entry in the pdb archive
a user guide and video tutorial are also
available for the mall star viewer
please visit rcsb.org and pdb101.rcsp
today to begin your journey into the
world of proteins
you